here's Moscow's largest airport about a year ago.
Here's the airport last week.
The biggest difference,
there are more planes.
Some of them shouldn't be here.
But most of those planes aren't leaving the country.
More than 400 aircraft owned by foreign leasing companies are stuck in Russia.
After President Vladimir Putin signed a law allowing airlines to take control of the planes.
In response to Western sanctions.
The aircraft,
which are valued at $10 billion,
are now caught in a battle between Russia and the West,
where both are trying to use the planes to punish the other.
So why is Russia holding onto these planes?
How does their seizure affect the west?
And what are the ripple effects of this fight on the broader aviation industry?
In response to Russia's invasion of Ukraine,
Western companies leveled a long list of sanctions against the country and directly targeted
its aviation industry from sanctions banning shipments on spare parts and new planes.
To this,
we will join our allies and closing off american airspace to all Russian flights.
Further isolating Russia,
All of these things are really designed to put Russia's aviation industry.
And among the sanctions was a requirement for Western leasing companies to cancel
contracts with Russian airlines and get their planes back.
And that's a big deal.
Western leasing companies owned 70% of Russia's 981 jets
in service or in storage if all of those aircraft were returned,
the domestic system within Russia would collapse.
But Russia wasn't always as reliant on Western aircraft,
here's a Russian T U 114 seen on a testing flight before the 19 nineties soviet
Union era aircraft ruled Russian skies.
But when the soviet union collapsed,
the market opened up and the need for new aircraft grew rather than buying
Boeing or Airbus planes,
Russian carriers leased them.
These aircraft helped open up Russian airlines like national carrier aeroflot to the west,
basically what we've seen over the last two decades is really Russia's aviation industry transforming
itself from kind of a soviet error reputation into really more of a world
class competitive industry.
And that's really all being pretty much undone by the invasion and the sanctions that are followed
under the sanctions Boeing.
Airbus and their suppliers are prohibited from sending parts and doing maintenance on the leased
planes that make up much of Russia's commercial fleet.
While this may not have an immediate impact,
it could have a lasting one.
What that means is that over time the safety record of Russia's airlines
is going to degrade right.
You're going to have aircraft that aren't maintained to the standards that they are meant to
be.
While Russia does manufacture a few aircraft domestically Syrian data shows much
of those planes rely on Western built engines and parts of the country can't get.
So what can Russian airlines do?
We've already seen reports and comments from the Russian government that they had,
for example approached china to try and find other ways of bringing in spare parts.
It sounds initially like china hasn't been willing to be after that kind of support for
the Russian airlines.
But a deal with china still wouldn't cover parts manufactured by Boeing and Airbus.
For those,
experts say Russia will likely end up cannibalizing aircraft basically using some planes as
part spins to keep others operational.
It's not quite clear what the long term solution is.
There's only so many times that that you can do that.
It's expected that,
you know,
within the next couple of years this will have a serious impact.
Meanwhile,
the seized aircraft are creating issues for the West.
Russia responded to the airspace closures by doing the same,
which has raised the question,
can the least aircraft actually be recovered?
Easy answers.
No,
it is,
it is not possible.
According to Syria,
nearly 80 planes have been returned so far,
but those were taken back outside of Russia.
Putin's moved to seize planes inside the country has created a multi billion dollar
problem for leasing companies and their insurers.
It's almost like weaponizing the value of these aircraft because it's going to become a an
insurance issue with that issue.
Who's going to pay for these planes?
They're valued at about $10 billion.
But experts say the insured value is even more perhaps as much as 15
billion.
While none of the leasing companies rely solely on the Russian market writing off billions isn't
something they want to do if all of those aircraft were written off.
It's,
it's not a great day for lessors,
but it wouldn't put a single less or out of business leasing companies could instead pass
the cost onto their insurers where the effect could cause more harm.
The biggest issue here is that I can't find anyone in the
industry who thinks the,
the,
The insurance market can withstand a $15 billion dollar claim.
Industry executives have said that this could lead to litigation that may take years to resolve
or two requests for government support.
Meanwhile,
experts say the confidence Western companies had in working in the Russian market has
eroded.
I think it will be very difficult for the lessons too.
And,
and and even more broader industry to return to to Russia
for years.
The extent to which any long term effects will be felt depends on how long Russia continues
to wage war in Ukraine.
Even if the invasion is resolved relatively quickly,
is still likely to be this lasting damage not only on the brands of these Russian airlines,
but also on their relationships with their Western partners,
but the sanctions have already begun to take a toll.
A spokeswoman for Moscow's largest airport said this week that the airport had furloughed
20% of its employees as activity at the airport has declined by approximately
70%.
And while these gates look active,
these terminals are now closed,
that's definitely something that the sanctions are designed to do is to put pressure on the
domestic aviation travel industry in Russia and kind of the knock on impact that that has on the
economy.